[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts à l'assemblée et au sénat
et pour commenter toute l'actualité de
cette semaine notre invité est
aujourd'hui romareda bonjour vous êtes
député et l'air de l'essonne merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
bonjour aux baradat vous êtes né à
savigny sur orge dans l'essonne
on va voir tout de suite vos papiers
voilà en 2014 et habitant de la commune
voisine de juvisy vos choisissent vous
devenez à 22 ans le plus jeune maire de
france vous fait basculer la vie la
droite et trois ans plus tard vous
entrez ici à l'assemblée député l'est
républicain de l'essonne en juin dernier
vous quittez le party les républicains
dans le sillage de valérie pécresse qui
a fondé son mouvement libre et qui
dénonce alors un partie cadenassée
c'était juste après la démission de
laurent wauquiez alors aujourd'hui
romareda c'est christian jacob qui à la
tête des républicains ce que vous
considérez toujours comme valérie
pécresse à l'époque que la refondation
de la droite ne peut pas se faire à
l'intérieur du parti
je crois que la refondation de la droite
aura besoin des républicains mais que
les républicains ne peuvent pas porter
aujourd'hui seule la refondation de la
droite parce que la droite est là
différentes composantes idéologique et
républicains représente plutôt la frange
conservatrice de la droite qui nous
faisait tous et respectable moi je
n'avais grèce on a souhaité fonder une
droite moderne c'est à dire une droite
qui ne renie pas ses valeurs qui ne
renie pas son stock qui est forte sur
les valeurs régaliennes sur l'autorité
de l'état par exemple métier aussi
beaucoup plus moderne et beaucoup plus
en phase avec son époque parce que c'est
ce qu'attendent les français
robin reda on arrive ainsi à vous situer
on va dérouler avec vous l'actualité
l'audition et l'examen est clair du
budget de la sécu à l'assemblée après
les annonces du gouvernement
hôpital en pleine grogne universitaire
le gouvernement rabote les crédits pour
la vie étudiante explication dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission et
puis l'assemblée a achevé l'examen du
projet de loi consacré à l'engagement
local
le texte fait l'objet de frictions entre
députés et sénateurs et on commence par
le sujet à la une de parlement hebdo
l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée un peu
modifiées par les annonces d'urgence du
gouvernement pour l'hôpital rallonge
budgétaire prime pour les soignants
reprise partielle de la dette
une partie des mesures du gouvernement
pour sauver l'hôpital seront mises en
oeuvre dès cette année dans le budget de
la sécu par le biais d'un amendement
auditions et claires de la ministre de
la santé devant les députés pour
expliquer le calendrier fanny die
le gouvernement a voulu faire vite
quelques heures après les annonces pour
l'hôpital
la ministre de la santé est auditionné à
l'assemblée une rallonge budgétaire d'un
milliard et demi d'euros sur trois ans
une reprise partielle de la dette
hospitalière mais aussi des primes pour
le personnel voilà les principales
mesures décidées elles seront intégrées
d'emblée au budget de la sécurité
sociale
c'est un effort conséquent et je voulais
je vous l'annonçais à présent un
amendement sera bien déposé par le
gouvernement en ce sens en amont de
votre discussion commission pour que
cette nouvelle lecture puisse se faire
en toute transparence et dans le cadre
de débats aussi clair que sincère avec
ce troisième plan le gouvernement espère
calmer la crise qui secoue l'hôpital
public depuis le mois de mars le groupe
mouvement démocrate et apparentés salue
l'effort budgétaire historique que le
gouvernement vient d'annoncer pour
soutenir l'hôpital public
pour l'opposition le compte n'y est pas
la droite qualifie ces mesures de
rafistolage
à court terme ça paraît davantage être
du rafistolage que l'ambition que
j'appelais que j'appelais de mes voeux
je considère en l'état de vos
observations que ce n'est pas un plan de
refondation du système de santé
c'est un plan d'apaisement de la colère
vous me direz que vous hérité d'une
situation ancienne comme n'y est pour
rien je connais cette chanson mais
aujourd'hui vous êtes aux manettes et
votre réponse désolé très satisfaisante
agnès buzyn répond vertement c'est le
cas quelle à précédent qui a aggravé la
dette hospitalière comme jamais donc il
faut arrêter
vous pouvez considérer que c'est
insuffisant mais me dire qu'on a perdu
du temps et que vous avez un plan
ambitieux pour l'hôpital public avec ce
qui a été fait depuis cinq ans je trouve
que quand même c'est fort de café
j'étais à l'hôpital public pendant que
vous étiez aux affaires je les ai vus
mois la dégradation gelé vue dans la
soirée la commission des affaires
sociales a voté pour l'intégration de
ces mesures d'urgence au projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
ce budget pour 2020 amende et sera
examiné dès lundi dans l'hémicycle voilà
séance en commission un peu agité et ce
que sur la méthode robert et dans robin
reda ça vous choque le gouvernement
passe un peu en force au parlement en
disant voilà le budget de la sécurité
sociale
il est un peu caduque donc on va on va
mettre les mesures directement dans ce
budget est ce que sur la méthode
c'est une bonne manière de faire ce que
fait le gouvernement d'annoncer des
mesures d'urgence et de modifier le
calendrier des débats à l'assemblée
ce qui me frappe c'est l'absence totale
de vision
quant à la politique de santé et en
particulier sur la question de l'hôpital
public et l'improvisation dans tout ça
c'est le flou artistique le plus total
on navigue totalement à vue sur la
question de l'hôpital pourquoi ça fait
deux ans et demi que ce gouvernement est
aux manettes ça fait deux ans et demi
que la mine de la santé qui fort
justement en tant que professionnel de
la santé en scène hospitalière s'alarme
on l'a entendu dans certains discours et
je le crois sincère sur la situation de
l'hôpital public et ça fait deux ans et
demi que le gouvernement n'a pas bougé
d'un iota
il ya eu quelques annonces effectivement
m'a expliqué qu'on allait sauver
réformer l'hôpital public à moyens
constants
ensuite on a expliqué qu' ever 750
millions d'euros mis sur la table et
puis tout d'un coup on sort 12 milliards
à la proche d'une journée sociale qui
promet d'être effectivement agitée pour
le gouvernement
début décembre et à la suite d'un été
noir 1 je le rappelle notamment pour nos
urgences que la rue paye que la
mobilisation et la rue ça mais
aujourd'hui je crois d'abord qu'il faut
pas réagir comme cela effectivement le
gouvernement et peut-être assez hâtif
dans la manière de faire mais ça fait
surtout deux ans et demi que la
situation des soignants que la situation
de l'hôpital est critique mais
effectivement elle est en grande partie
héritée et d'hériter deux ans et demi
depuis deux ans et demi en fin de ça
fait donc deux
''j'ai plus en ce moment en discussion
il y avait largement des possibilités
pour le gouvernement de redresser la
situation finalement cette toux
plusieurs gouvernements doivent porter
la responsabilité de cette situation
aujourd'hui on a entendu le chant
j'adore jouer à la vignery
moi je m'amuse beaucoup elle critique le
creusement de la dette ce qui est vrai
des hôpitaux sous le quinquennat
précédent rappelle juste que le
président de la république et ministre
de l'économie à ce moment là et que
peut-être que la question notamment de
la dette hospitalière auraient pu être
prises en amont en critiquent aussi la
gouvernance et ça c'est plutôt la loi
bachelot non seulement on a des
responsabilités dans la relation ça fait
ça fait 15 ans je pense que notamment
une forme de technocratie en santé a
fait mourir l'hôpital public n'est donc
effectivement il faut tout faire pour
réinvestir sur l'hôpital public je pense
qu'on va venir sourire quelques mesures
de fond mais sur la forme encore une
fois à prendre au milieu de la
discussion du budget de la sécurité
sociale alors qu'il ya trois quatre
semaines on nous disait durera pas
d'augmentation de moyens pour les de
l'irrespect du parlement mais c'est sûr
et ne pas respirer débarrassant total de
lucidité de ce qui se passe dans nos
territoires vous savez que ce soit en
milieu urbain comme chez moi ou des
hôpitaux les hôtels de juvisy sur orge
et vouée à la fermeture depuis des
années alors qu'il dessert un bassin de
santé de 200 mille habitants ou dans des
milieux plus ruraux où on sait bien que
la disparition d'un hôpital fait
disparaître notamment l'offre de soin
d'eux mais aussi des emplois locaux tout
cela est une réalité nos territoires qui
a tardé de prise en compte
omar aide a effectivement un place au
fond des mesures de ce plan d'urgence
lors de la séance des questions
d'actualité au sénat mercredi la droite
a attaqué le gouvernement jugeant que
son plan n'est pas à la hauteur écouter
cet échange il a les attendait les
professionnels de santé un plan de
sauvetage
ils n'ont eu que du rafistolage pourquoi
monsieur bré ministre n'avez vous pas
fait le choix d'une réforme en
profondeur de l'hôpital mettre sur la
table sur les trois ans qui viennent un
milliard et demi d'euros d'argent neuf
frais y ajouter à ces 1 milliard et demi
d'euros
les 450 millions ou plus exactement les
150 millions annuels pendant trois ans
pour financer de l'investissement
médicale nous avons décidé d'opérer une
reprise de dettes je n'ai pas le
souvenir qu'une telle reprise de dette
était couramment
alizée dans le cadre de l'hôpital public
10 milliards de dette en trois ans et
massif sur l'ampleur de ce plan vous de
quel avis et vous on entend rafistolage
1 du côté du président de la commission
des affaires sociales du sénat et de
l'autre côté et bien edouard philippe
qui dit que c'est un plan massif est ce
que vous jugez que les moyens mis au
service de ce plan sont suffisants
d'abord je crois qu'il faut mettre
effectivement des moyens pour l'hôpital
public et la sq ici et c'est un homme de
droite qui vous le dis je crois que
l'hôpital public la santé
c'est aujourd'hui une des missions
principales de l'état régalien au même
titre que la sécurité ou la défense la
santé nos concitoyens c'est quelque
chose qui doit être piloté pris en
charge en principalement par l'état
c'est vraiment assez d'argent sur la
table je crois que c'est en effet une
perfusion qui est proposé aujourd'hui
parce qu'il n'y a pas de réforme
profonde de l'hôpital il faut
effectivement des moyens supplémentaires
mais il faut aussi repenser l'hôpital
parce qu'il ya une bouffée dati a les
moyens très importants en france pour la
santé on consacre 11 % de notre pib aux
dépenses de santé donc on peut pas dire
que la france dépense peu pour sa santé
en revanche on a bien vu que il y avait
un gaspillage de l'argent à l'hôpital
pourquoi est un gaspillage d'abord parce
que il ya beaucoup d'hôpitaux qui sont
vétustes et qui dit matériel vétuste aux
locaux vétustes 18 consommation dès
qu'il faut investir à rénover tous ces
mois d'autre part on a des rigidités de
statut d'abord de la fonction publique
hospitalière et ensuite on a des
problématiques rh dans les hôpitaux un
poids de ministres hâtif très lourd au
au détriment parfois des soignants donc
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que si
on ne fait pas une réforme globale de ce
que sont les hôpitaux n'est la manière
dont il fonctionne cet argent il
continuera à tourner et vous et a
procédé à produire non pas de meilleure
qualité de soin mais à perfuser un
hôpital public à bout de souffle vous
faites tourner d'accord sur le constat
est ce que vous avez un contre plan pour
sauver l'hôpital public et qu'elle doit
être pour vous la priorité pour sauver
ce modèle français de d'hôpital public a
priori deux géants cité une la priorité
pour moi c'est d'investir dans nos
hôpitaux et surtout de ne pas laisser
mourir voire de réhabiliter des hôpitaux
de proximité
parce que qui dit hôpitaux de proximité
dit que les grands hôpitaux en
particulier universitaires peuvent être
recentrée sur les soins
deux auteurs j'allais dire de soins de
plus important voilà qui demande plus de
de technicité donc il faut une
hiérarchie hospitalière notamment pour
la prise en charge des urgences
ce que d'ailleurs ce plan ne cite pas du
tout la situation d urgence alors que
c'était le grand cas urgents de 750
millions particulièrement consacrée aux
urgences mais enfin on n'en n'a toujours
pas vu la couleur
donc ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'il faut une meilleure hiérarchie des
hôpitaux des hôpitaux de premier recours
de proximité qui ferait la risée les
petites urgences et puis des grands
hôpitaux qui prennent en charge les
soins médicaux les plus techniques cette
hiérarchie là elle permet aussi de
savoir où mettre les soignants et de
mieux gérer les ressources humaines de
l'hôpital au marais d'ahvaz passe au
deuxième thème de cette émission les
étudiants qui font les frais du budget
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le parlement a bouclé cette semaine le
budget 2010 neuf parmi les ajustements
de fin d'année il en est un qui passe
mal la suppression de 35 millions
d'euros réservés au financement de la
vie étudiante explications aux rêves
états
quinze jours après la tentative de
suicide d'un jeune à lyon sur fond de
précarité étudiante le coup de rabot
passe mal pour boucler son budget 2010 9
le gouvernement supprime 35 millions
d'euros de crédits réservés au
financement de la vie étudiante et des
bourses
ils auraient dû servir à rénover des
résidences étudiantes ou à créer des
dispensaires de santé sur les campus
le gouvernement s'explique certes ces
crédits vie étudiante sont supprimés
mais d'autres sont gardés ça nous permet
de payer les bourses les traitements de
personnel assurer le bon fonctionnement
des crous et financer les aides dont
peuvent bénéficier les étudiants
il n'empêche pour les sénateurs il ne
faut rien toucher sur proposition des
groupes socialistes et communistes
le scrutin est ouvert ils votent contre
le coup de rabot
oui mais voilà à l'étape d'après la
commission mixte paritaire composée de
sept députés et sept sénateurs supprime
les fameux 35 millions d'euros
leur explication la somme est minime
comparé à tout ce qui est fait par le
gouvernement pour les étudiants la garde
et ne serait que démagogie réponses
incompréhensibles pour pierre rouge
oulias il ya une forme de double langage
parce que dans l'hémicycle on a bien vu
qu'il y avait un consensus pour dire qu
en effet compte tenu de la situation des
étudiants des universités c'est
important de faire un geste politique et
de restituer à l'enseignement supérieur
c'est 35 millions nous étions d'accord
donc ce qui s'est passé ensuite en
commission mixte paritaire je ne
m'explique pas la pilule passe mal
d'autant que les crédits réservés au
patrimoine sont eux conserver ce qui est
engagée pour la sauvegarde des monuments
historiques peut l'être aussi pour une
université
surtout que vu l'état de délabrement des
universités parfois ça ressemble
un monument historique aussi c'est un
patrimoine en péril universités si les
choses sont actés pour 2019 le
gouvernement promet qu'en 2020 le budget
de la vie étudiante augmentera de 70
millions d'euros 35 millions d'euros qui
ont donc été supprimés au budget des
étudiants pour 2019 c'est parce qu'il
n'avait pas été consommés à un robin
reda mais c'est quand même très ironique
de se dire qu'on a fait donc des
économies qui reste de l'argent la fin
de l'année 2019 et qu'en même temps il
ya autant d'étudiants dans des
situations de précarité alarmante
un point sur la méthode déjà parce qu'on
parlait de l'hôpital à l'instant mais
c'est un petit peu la même question si
vous voulez il faut que avec les
français nous regardions maintenant ce
que le gouvernement fait de notre argent
parce qu'il ya les effets d annonce
notamment au moment du vote du budget il
ya on augmente les crédits on augmente
les moyens on va mettre tant et tant de
millions ou milliards sur la table pour
tel ou tel secteur
et puis à la fin ce qu'on en a fait
c'est ça qui fait évidemment ça qui
compte c'est médiatiquement parfois
moins mis en avant notamment par le
gouvernement parce que c'est ça qui
solde le bilan et notamment sur la vie
étudiante
ça veut dire que il ya un an au moment
du budget on avait été ambitieux sur la
vie étudiante qu'on avait fait pour
certains confiance au gouvernement en
disant oh mon mal y aura des moyens qui
seront ne laissez pas le cas les
étudiants et puis finalement on voit
bien que le gouvernement se range pas
avoir quelques crédits de réserve pour
l'année d'après et puis il reporte
finalement un certain nombre de soi de
travaux de rénovation soit des deux
étudiants par exemple on concept on
constate effectivement sur les aides aux
étudiants que chaque année il reste 15
millions sur l'aide d'urgence c'est
aussi parce que les étudiants ne savent
pas que ça existe quand même on marche
un peu sur la tête
est ce que quand la miss propose un
numéro vert pour tous les étudiants vous
pensez que ça peut suffire pour que tous
les étudiants sachent qu'on peut avoir
recours à ce type entre la vie étudiante
c'est le moment de l'autonomie cette
autonomie elle est plus ou moins
complexes à à conquérir pour pour
certains parce que quand on est étudiant
sort du lycée où les choses étaient plus
cadré on est parfois loin de sa famille
parce qu'on part étudier dans des dents
dans des grandes villes et donc faut
apprendre à se débrouiller seul avec un
quotidien qui évidemment pas facile je
crois que le coni tous les étudiants on
est nombreux à l'avoir connu
c'est évidemment pas elle quelque chose
de toujours très très agréable mais pour
autant il ya un parcours d'autonomie et
construire et je crois que notamment
s'agissant des aides aux étudiants il
faut effectivement renforcer
l'information la formation a les clés et
l'information elle passe par les
universités elles passent par les
associations et les syndicats étudiants
elle parle évidemment par le
gouvernement et ce serait très cynique
de mettre en place des moyens
et puis de ne pas inciter les étudiants
à les consommer ou en bénéficier qu'est
ce que vous pensez de la manière dont le
gouvernement s'y prend pour s'adresser
aux étudiants et notamment emmanuel
macron qui était ce jeudi à amiens et ce
qui s'y prend bien
j'ai vu les interventions des manuels
macron a amené renommant les étudiants
parfois un peu un peu sec avec ce qu'ils
vivent à ce qu'on ne peut pas nier ce
qui a évidemment des associations et ça
a toujours existé qui instrumentalisent
un peu la situation de certains et là il
ya une sorte avant les élections de fin
novembre penser qu'il ya une
instrumentalisation de la glace moi je
n'y suis pas dupe de l'agitation
politique que l'on peut faire autour de
la question des universités ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la situation des
étudiantes et des étudiants manière
individuelle et la manière dont on les
aide à s'en sortir à faire des études
correctement à trouver éventuellement un
job étudiant à côté et puis à les aider
à se loger et à se nourrir les besoins
élémentaires d'un étudiant et
effectivement si le gouvernement
détourne la tête de cette grande cause
nationale pour moi bien c'est assez
cynique parce que on a les moyens de le
faire en tout cas on les a votés donc je
ne vois pas pourquoi on n'hésiterait pas
gabriel attal et puis ensuite frédéric
vidal ont reçu tout de même les
étudiants mais une annonce finalement
pas vraiment de moyens supplémentaires
et parle beaucoup du revenu universel
d'activité ce comme un projet de très
long terme
est ce que pour vous ça peut être une
solution justement bien pour pour lutter
contre la précarité étudiante
oui c'est un des instruments une piste
mais aujourd'hui la première précarité
étudiante c'est le logement et notamment
s'agissant du logement la baisse brutale
des aides au logement
en début de quelques ébats fait beaucoup
de mal c'est un mail qui traîne à 10
mais au caire et à mesure mais ça a été
un symbole fort pas que pour les
étudiants d'ailleurs parce que
évidemment qu'il faut repenser
probablement la manière dont on loge les
étudiants et les français et manière
dont on dépense de l'argent alors que
certains ont toujours du mal à se loger
mais la manière brutale et le coup de
rabot qui a été fait au début du
quinquennat n'a pas aidé à rétablir un
lien de confiance entre les
organisations étudiantes entre les
étudiants et gouvernement
on va passer au troisième thème de cette
émission romareda l'assemblée a achevé
ce jeudi la discussion du projet de loi
examiné pour répondre au malaise des
maires et députés ont notamment voté un
dispositif de compromis pour tenter de
revaloriser les indemnités des maires de
certaines petites communes écouté les
explications du ministre en séance
sébastien lecornu
moi je vous propose de garder cet esprit
dans lequel il n'y a pas d'augmentation
automatique des élus puisque bon nombre
de collègues élus locaux sur le terrain
nous disent je ne demande pas forcément
être augmenté il faut savoir aussi
longtemps à la fois collectivement nous
voulons leur bien pour être un peu
génériques et nous souhaitons pouvoir
mieux les indemniser
mais certains pour tout un tas de
raisons sur lequel je rentrerai pas dans
le détail les situations personnelles
situation politique des situations
géographiques distinctes cumul le non
cumul de retraite de pas de retraite
bref autant de situations de cave qui
les regardent
évidemment je pense qu'il est bon de ne
pas prévoir d'automaticité pas
d'augmentation automatique comme le
voulait sénateurs mais la mise en place
d'une grille de rémunération vous étiez
en séance robin reda est-ce que ce
dispositif est satisfaisant et
finalement c'est bien la preuve qu'un
compromis entre députés et sénateurs est
possible non pour moi c'est une méthode
désastreuse pourquoi je vous explique
parce que quand on est maire d'une
petite commune de moins de 3500
habitants on a une rémunération brute
qui est entre 600 euros et 1600 euros en
fonction de la strate de la commune par
tranche de 500 habitants pour un travail
qui pour les petites communes travail de
maire est parfois plus important en tout
cas plus direct que le travail de maire
d'une grande commune parce que quand
vous êtes maire d'une petite commune
vous avez moins de personnels pour vous
et des instructeurs
une structure vous devez faire beaucoup
plus de choses par vous même parce que
plus de dépenses simplement payer vous
devez aussi continuer à travailler
souvent à côté si vous n'êtes pas
retraités pour pouvoir avoir un niveau
de vie décent et vous gagnez moins que
la plupart des cadres de votre
collectivité
donc il est une réalité c'est que les
maires de france en particulier des
petites communes sont sous payés par
rapport à leurs heures de travail est
alors responsable donc ce qui a été voté
à l'assemblée ne répond pas ce qui a été
voté et cynique c'est que plutôt qu
effectivement d'avoir une grille qui
augmente les indemnités des maires pour
les communes les plus petits de moins de
3500 habitants là on laissera aux votes
des conseils municipaux la
responsabilité d'augmenter l'indemnité
du maire
vous imaginez la responsabilité
politique d'un maire qui certes est je
pense que ses habitants le savent
travaille beaucoup et sous payés mais ne
voudra pas prendre le risque d'avoir
dans la dent dans la presse quotidienne
régionale ou petit article qui lui
expliquera de 130%
j'ajoute que lorsque l'on fait une
grille de d'indemnités c'est un plafond
rien n'empêche au maire à qui on
présente une grille d'indemnités
maximale de réduire moi lorsque j'ai été
élu maire le vous dire on avait réduit
les indemnités des élus et du maire de
10% j'étais l'une une ville de 15 mille
habitants donc rien n'empêche par
rapport à une grille de réduire son
indemnité
par ailleurs ce qui est cynique aussi
c'est que c'est les communes qui paye
l'indemnité du maire 500 habitants bien
le maire devra arbitrer entre augmenter
de quelques euros
son indemnité ou refaire la poubelle
de telle ou telle rue donc vous voyez
bien qu'on on est en train de mettre les
élus locaux et aux vertus et les maires
dans une situation inconfortable donc ce
n'est pas du tout satisfaisant pour vous
en tout cas la discussion sur ce texte a
donné lieu à un véritable bras de fer
entre les deux chambres du parlement les
sénateurs rappelons le avait voté le
texte modifié à l'unanimité et ne sont
donc pas du tout content de la version
qui est sorti de l'assemblée notamment
de la version qui était sorti de la
commission on va refaire le film de la
semaine avec jérôme rabier une adoption
sénatoriale à l'unanimité moins deux
voix des sourires et des formules de
politesse pour saluer un dialogue
fructueux et pourtant un mois après le
vote du projet de loi engagement et
proximité par la chambre haute
le climat n'est plus du tout au beau
fixe entre le sénat et la majorité
gouvernementale sur ce sujet en cause
l'examen en commission des lois à
l'assemblée où les députés sont revenus
sur plusieurs points tel est revenu sur
le transfert facultative de l'eau et
assainissement et surtout sur ce qui est
très attendue par les élus locaux s'est
refait pas de nouvelle révolution mais
on permet à chacun de s'adapter et de
transférer des compétences à la carte au
congrès des maires de france les
sénateurs ont reçu le soutien de
nombreux maires dans ce bras de fer et
en particulier à la tribune pourquoi
faudrait-il encore systématiquement en
permanence revenir sur des avancées qui
satisfont la quasi totalité des
partenaires
mais pour le ministre en charge des
collectivités territoriales les
ajustements sont mineurs et vista
corriger des mesures mal rédigé ou
financièrement trop coûteuse la
commission des lois a décidé de corriger
ce sont deux choses pour permettre aux
députés dans l'hémicycle de le faire
cette semaine peu plus les députés ne
sont pas venus s'ingérer comme cela dans
la discussion au sénat et dessinateur ne
leur est pas permis donc les deux
chambres vont trouver comme les en ont
l'habitude d'ailleurs la convergence
qu'il va bien les sénateurs réclame à
l'assemblée de revoir sa copie en séance
faute de quoi il ne pourra y avoir
d'accord en commission mixte paritaire
c'est la condition sinequanone d'un
accord en cmp la volonté ça n'est pas
d'avoir un texte à l'eau tiède qui in
fine ne satisferait pas
les élus locaux la volonté du
gouvernement d'arriver à une application
avant le 31 décembre semble désormais
s'éloigner
à moins que le sénat au simplement le
ton pour montrer aux maires réunis en
congrès qu'il reste leur meilleur
défenseur romareda ce que vous croyez à
un accord possible entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce que dit
sébastien lecornu le bicamérisme ça
marche dans les deux sens le sénat a pas
tellement à se mêler de ce que fait
l'assemblée lorsqu'elle travaille sur le
texte
oui ce qui est incroyable c'est que les
députés de la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale ont réussi à briser la belle
unanimité qui existait autour de la
nécessité de ce texte parce que je crois
mais tous favorables à un projet de loi
qui améliorent le quotidien des maires
et qui les incite soit ceux représentés
soit qui incite des nouveaux citoyens à
devenir meilleur gens à quelques mois
des municipales maman c'est urgent sauf
que les questions principales ont été
soit raboté par l'assemblée nationale
soit n'ont pas été abordés lorsqu'on
parle de la présence du maire dans
l'intercommunalité
il ya eu des ajustements techniques à la
marge mais rien sur les périmètres xxl
des intercommunalités kinois nos
communes nos villes dans des grands
ensembles qui sont mal identifiées par
les citoyens sur les pouvoirs de police
le sénat avait fait plein de
propositions notamment issus du rapport
d'arnaud oui l'assemblée nationale est
revenu sur énormément de choses qui
permettait au maire d'agir et d'agir
contre ce sentiment d'impunité qui
parfois gangrène nos villes parce que
lorsque vous avez un débit de boisson
par exemple qui ne ferment pas aux
horaires où il devrait fermer distribuer
de l'alcool sans licence et que vous
avez le maire qui est démuni face aux
citoyens qu'ils interpellent face aux
nuisances et qui ne peut pas verbalisés
qui ne peut pas sanctionner sur le champ
eh bien vous avez une véritable rupture
de vous entendre
l'action politique et les citoyens et
tout ça on est on est enfin les députés
de la majorité sont revenu dessus en
qu'ils ont raté l'objectif principal de
ce texte c'était quand même de plaire au
maire de revaloriser la fonction vous
dites c'est raté en tout cas c'est
largement insuffisant par rapport à ce
que vivent les maires au quotidien on a
parlé des indemnités et un instant on
renvoie la responsabilité au maire de
s'augmenter eux-mêmes d'en prendre la
responsabilité politique sur les
pouvoirs de police
évidemment les maires doivent avoir plus
de pouvoir sous contrôle de l'autorité
préfectorale pour pouvoir répondre aux
situations qui leur sont posées parce
que sinon on a l'impression qu'ils sont
totalement impuissants
c'est derrière leur impuissance c'est
l'état qui par un puissant pour les
citoyens ce sera le mot de la fin
merci romareda merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à cette émission la semaine
prochaine notre invité sera patrick
kanner le patron des sénateurs
socialistes
ciao
[Musique]